à l'étranger c'est un geste qui
attendaient la communauté internationale
la corée du nord a confirmé l'arrêt de
son principal site nucléaire une
première étape d'un long processus qui
prévoit la désactivation complète de
l'ensemble des programmes nucléaire du
régime de pyongyang quelques
explications avec yasmina farber après
cinq ans d'absence
une dizaine d'inspecteurs de l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique
arrive en corée du nord chargé de
matériel les experts confirment leur
mission nous allons directement vers le
complexe nucléaire de pyongyang
l'ong bio est le principal complexe
nucléaire de corée du nord c'est ici que
sont retraités des barres de combustible
irradiées destiné à fabriquer des bombes
nucléaires
les autorités ont annoncé la fermeture
du site et invité les inspecteurs
internationaux à vérifier cet arrêt la
corée du nord avait pris cet engagement
il ya cinq mois en contrepartie des
d'énergétique 6200 tonnes de fioul ont
d'ailleurs été livrées de corée du sud
dès hier mais le négociateur américain
reste prudent il faut utiliser cette
étape pour aller plus loin l'objectif
principal reste de désactiver tous les
programmes nucléaires le régime
stalinien de pyongyang avait fait
exploser sa première bombe atomique il
ya neuf mois
le conseil de sécurité des nations unies
avaient voté des sanctions économiques
et commerciales
depuis les négociations ont repris la
communauté internationale attend le
démantèlement complet des programmes
nucléaires